I remember getting on the plane and
eating the edible and it was me like
Martin and Gabriel and we were sitting
across from tree like old women and also
the edibles started hitting me right
mm-hmm and I'm 380 I'm [__] huge it
really it must been Mesirow I had to be
380 this is like 10 years ago I'm gonna
forget taking my shirt off and the sweat
was pouring down me and these little old
ladies were just looking at the floor
and there I am [__] sweat another
time I went to doubt that took a header
book like I'm so hungry the package set
of inserts that's a mistake
cinnamon makes you sweat like a
[__] healing dog I started
sweating on the plane there was a little
gay guy next to me and he was asleep
people put those little things on their
eyes I had to take my shirt off there I
am the first class with the blanket up
to my stomach my tits are out
yeah you could feel the beat I remember
getting off the plane in Miami next
morning and my pants were [__] wet
and to store this we're just walking the
halls look at me and give me a water she
know how [__] up I was